[Musique]
bonjour est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 le journal voici les
titres ce matin l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines a présenté ce k
invest d'un outil de financement
participatif
son but aider au développement des
entreprises focus sur les candidats à la
législative de debout la france dans les
yvelines
présent dans toutes les circonscriptions
ils souhaitent peuvent représenter
l'après droite sur le territoire partir
à la retraite peut être une véritable
angoisse
l'assurance retraite fait évoluer ses
modalités d'accueil à partir du 2 juin
le point sur les nouveautés dans ce
journal
attention sujet inflammable depuis le 26
mai à l'appel de la cgt un mouvement de
conducteurs de camions citernes menace
de paralyser les dépôts de carburant à
quelques jours des élections
législatives
ils réclament une amélioration de leurs
conditions de travail
cette grève nationale s'est poursuivie
aujourd'hui notamment à coignières
écouter l'un des grévistes
nos revendications déjà c'est la
reconnaissance md et il y aurait tout ce
qui touche la matière dangereuse vu les
conditions de travail les protocoles et
procédures rue et qui nous sont demandés
les formations et autres entre
inadmissible que de nos jours qu'on ne
soit pas reconnu qu'on n'est pas d'âne
ex-uni de gris dans ce domaine on prend
la direction du ski tube ce matin
l'agglomération a présenté sky invest un
outil de financement participatif
son but aider au développement des
entreprises regardez développement
innovation embauche les entreprises de
saint quentin en yvelines peuvent
maintenant faire appel au financement
participatif pour mener à bien leurs
projets particuliers ou professionnels
deviennent alors acteurs de l'économie
locale des financeurs sont vous et moi
si vous avez
1000 5000 euros à placer plutôt que de
le mettre sur un livret a dont vous
savez qu'il vous rapportera pas grand
chose vous pouvez aller sur le site voir
si un projet vous séduit il ya deux
outils soient des prêts donc vous prêter
sous forme d'investissements soit vous
rentrez au capital et vous devenez
actionnaire de cette entreprise
le dispositif s'adresse aux entreprises
du territoire
immatriculée au registre du commerce et
des sociétés pour le mettre en place
la communauté d'agglomération a créé un
partenariat avec l'entreprise kiosque to
invest ça sera soit toutes les start up
pme toutes les structures corps et des
besoins de financement pour financer
leur développement leur croissance qui
auraient un besoin donc en fonds propres
entre 100000 euros et 2 min ou cinq les
seules contraintes on va dire juridique
c'est que la société soit et ça ou ss ou
en mesure de le devenir et ensuite et
qu'elle ait réalisé un premier chiffre
d'affaires ou alors une promesse
première promesse de chiffre d'affaires
pour déposer votre projet ou allez les
découvrir
rendez vous sur le site de sky invest
depuis sa création il ya quelques mois
la plateforme a déjà recueilli trois
demandes de financement les projets sont
actuellement en cours de validation
toujours au ski club a à peine un an de
vie et voici un nouvel appel à
candidatures pour les entrepreneurs
souhaitant à intégrer la structure
les dossiers sont à déposer du 15 mai au
15 juin
ecoutez jean luc romero le directeur au
micro de camille lambert
c'est un accompagnement très spécifique
technique
et qui permet à ces jeunes startups
d'avoir des informations des conseils de
la formation et un accompagnement
vraiment adapté à leurs besoins pour
leur permettre de
de développer
de se développer à la fois dans les
meilleures conditions et dans un laps de
temps le plus rapide possible
on passe à la politique et focus sur les
candidats du parti de nicolas dupont
aignan debout la france pour les
législatives
les candidats des yvelines souhaite
imposer leur vision de la droite dans le
département lors du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle leur champion
nicolas dupont aignan obtenu 4,34 % des
voix dans le département malgré son
alliance éphémère lors du second tour
avec le front national le parti a
présenté des candidats dans toutes les
circonscriptions comme sylvia cantaluppi
dans la 11e qui brigue le poste de
benoît hamon le député sortant son but
prolonger le programme de son champion
la moralisation de la vie politique donc
sur des élus sur un renouvellement et
des élus propre et avec des casiers
judiciaires vierges
bien évidemment et une un comportement
qu'ils soient citoyens et qui ne se
croit pas au dessus de la loi et des
forces de l'ordre
ce n'est pas la première fois que sylvia
cantaluppi se présente elle était déjà
candidate en 2012 et avait obtenu 0 68%
des voix pour d'autres candidats c'est
la première fois comme joël bosch
candidat dans la 10e circonscription des
yvelines
il partage les idées de nicolas dupont
aignan depuis 2014
son thème de campagne la solidarité moi
ce que je déplore beaucoup celle à
l'augmentation de la pauvreté en france
donc
d on a de plus en plus de chômeurs plus
en plus de pauvres solidarité
indépendance de la france ou encore
donner la parole au peuple ses candidats
souhaite s'imposer comme la vraie droite
républicaine en france ces idées qui ont
séduit emmanuel bojan candidat dans la
première circonscription des yvelines
l'idée c'est de pouvoir représenter une
droite sociale une droite humaniste une
droite gaulliste qui ne soit pas à
géométrie variable est prête à renier
ses valeurs après avoir longuement
critiqué emmanuel macron avant le
premier tour et si être beaucoup rallié
après le après le premier dans la 12e
circonscription c'est fabien mettay qui
représentera debout la france dans le
fief de david douillet dans la 2e
circonscription c'est françois sorel qui
tentera d'obtenir le poste de pascal
thévenot dans la troisième
circonscription c'est thibaut tournier
qui représentera le parti de nicolas
dupont aignan et dans cette course aux
législatives d'autres candidats
participent comme jérémy bizet dans la
2e circonscription avant tu t'en c'est
la deuxième fois que cet habitant de
cerner la ville se présente
investi par france écologie ses
principaux axes de campagne sont la
défense du territoire et l'écologie
réaliste si j'ai souhaité me présenter
c'est que je suis investi localement
depuis des années
pour défendre notre territoire le pnr
qui souvent menacés et pour toutes les
communes rurales en fait de sa
conception mais aussi de france qui sont
souvent les oubliés du débat politique
et deux réunions publiques sont
organisées ce soir par les républicains
la première françois-xavier bellamy
candidat dans la première
circonscription se déroule à 19h30 dans
le quartier saint louis à l'école tarot
à versailles
l'autre rendez vous a lieu à 20h30 à la
salle de la torah voisins le bretonneux
elle est organisée par le maire de
vélizy villacoublay pascal thévenot
candidat dans la 2e circonscription
c'était l'un des sujets de la
présidentielle partir à la retraite
peut-être une véritable angoisse
si vous ne savez pas comment faire pour
répondre au mieux à ses assurés
l'assurance retraite fait évoluer ses
modalités d'accueil à partir du 2 juin
le point sur les nouveautés avec cabine
lambert c'est la première rencontre avec
sa conseillère xavier fait le chemin de
croissy sur seine jusqu'à cette agence
retraite de saint quentin en yvelines
une étape indispensable pour préparer
son passage à la retraite
je fais une demande de retraite
progressive et donc effectivement d
des compléments d'information j'ai
besoin pour pouvoir avoir un dossier
plein complet pour pouvoir démarrer
correctement son bon pied bon oeil de
précision en particulière sur comment ça
pousse démouler c'est un chaque jour
cette agence s'occupe d'une centaine de
personnes qui comme vous aviez se
prépare à partir à la retraite
les assurés sont reçus sans rendez vous
mais à partir du 2 juin les modalités
d'accueil évolue désormais les assurés
seront obligés de prendre rendez vous
avec un conseiller
un service sur mesure cela nous
permettra de conserver ce moment
privilégié parce que le passage à la
retraite et comme la main moment un peu
anxiogène donc nous allons privilégier
ce mode de contact
nous répondons à une vraie demande
aujourd'hui les assurés vienne patiente
en salles d'attentes pour obtenir leurs
informations
là ça va permettra d'avoir un conseil
personnalisé pour prendre rendez-vous
direction le site internet de
l'assurance retraite dans un souci de
modernisation
le site se veut également plus
informatif pour éviter aux assurés de se
déplacer en agence
l'an dernier plus de 600 13000 personnes
ont pris leur retraite
grâce au travail de la municipalité de
saint cyr l'école et d'avenir api une
visite d'un institut de beauté étaient
proposés à six jeunes filles atteintes
de déficience intellectuelle
une occasion de découvrir des gestes
simples pour prendre soin d'elle
reportage de stéphane servant moment de
détente et de plaisir pour ces six
jeunes filles atteintes de déficience
intellectuelle
la visite d'un institut de beauté va
avoir une personne qui va nous apprendre
à apprendre sur notre peau à des femmes
janick l'esthéticienne leur a fait
découvrir son salon et les a initiés au
maquillage elle aura donné des conseils
de soins
une élue de la ville accompagne le
travail du centre spécialisé qui
s'occupe de ces jeunes adultes
il s'est passé un petit moment de
bonheur mais
encore une fois c'est pas parce que ce
sont des gens différents qu'il faut les
traiter différemment ils ont les mêmes
besoins sont les mêmes le centre
d'accueil de jour de saint cyr l'école
gérée par l'association avenir à pays
accueille ainsi une trentaine de jeunes
adultes âgés de 18 à 25 ans qui sont
atteints de déficience intellectuelle
légère à moyenne ils vont être
accompagnés dans ce centre pendant
quatre à cinq ans la mission principale
c'est la transition et c'est de prendre
du temps pour savoir ce que je veux
faire parce qu'à 18 ans 19 ans on sait
pas encore où on va aller habiter on
sait pas encore quel métier on veut
faire on a besoin de prendre du temps
tout est fait pour développer leur
autonomie dans leur vie quotidienne par
des ateliers des stages des teams de
soin d'hygiène de soin de son corps
comme cette visite aujourd'hui c'était
super j'ai bien aimé dans quelques mois
quelques années elles quitteront le
centre trouveront un métier un logement
comme toutes les autres jeunes filles
trois molières obtenu hier soir pour des
co productions du théâtre montansier de
versailles
la première récompense et pour seul en
scène d'emmanuel noblet avec réparer les
vivent les femmes savantes mise en scène
par catherine hiégel est reparti avec
deux statuettes meilleur comédien pour
jean pierre bacri et meilleur second
rôle pour evelyne bouix halle
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de nous avoir suivis
[Musique]